I hope you're having a fantastic day my
name is Nia and I'm the black female
engineer and today we're going to fill
some things that some of yall are going
through at work I'm going to go through
the Fishbowl app this is not sponsored
for those who don't know Fishbowl is an
app where people in the workplace can go
in and just like vent and also seek
advice it's really great for things like
salary transparency let's say if you got
an offer for a certain company you can
go on there it's all Anonymous go on
there and say like hey this is my offer
offer is the role um do y'all think it's
a good deal what are y'all being paid if
you're in this company things like that
kind of like glass door but like a lot
more interaction and sometimes a lot
more like unhinged so yeah we're going
to have fun let's just let's go into it
okay first up let's see should I give
two weeks notice or leave immediately my
manager is being extremely problematic
intentionally difficult and has been
treating me very badly well mocked in
our morning standups HR won't do
anything upper management has condemned
this behavior and vowed to correct the
situation but nothing has changed in
about two months because of this I don't
see any future here and have landed
another R okay that's amazing is there
any point in giving the standard two we
notice not going to lie to y'all I've
never given a two week notice I don't
see the point in me being courteous to
you when you were unkind to me like this
person is saying that yeah you are just
being unkind her manager just being
unkind and just mistreating her and so I
don't know that's me I understand the
implications not giving a two week
notice can create but also at the same
time like this person has already gotten
another job it's not like they give you
an offer and now they're going to call
up your old job for a referral you know
what I mean so I say leave it let's say
you get in trouble for breaking policy
and then report others for breaking the
same policy under the GU of maintaining
the the policy amongst everyone bro if
you get fired after that is that
retaliation for you complaining or can
employers not get in trouble I'm sorry I
think one that's so frustrating when so
many people are doing this thing and you
were the only one reprimanded it's like
no I'm bringing everyone in their mama
down with me like we're not playing that
but the thing is you're not saying that
you didn't break a certain policy like
you're saying like you did and you were
represented but you're upset that other
people weren't which is extremely valid
that being said they are entitled to
fire you for breaking the policy you
know but just suck that like yeah you're
the only one getting in trouble oh this
is interesting I just started a new
company and I'm getting chased by a
project manager she's talking as if I've
been here for a while and I know
everything she's trying to intimidate
and challenge me I'm a new hire and I
feel really scared on how to talk to her
can someone help it's too early for
alcoh that sucks
like especially as a new hire you're
trying so hard to put on the best face
and give your best work but then it's
like I can only give my best work if I
feel supported and if I'm getting
support in this role and so I would go
to your project manager um it doesn't
have to be like a formal thing but I
presume because you're a new hire you do
have touch points with your project
manager one on one and so when you are
given a new task ask the questions I say
there's a solid six month months where
you can ask any question at that you
want there's no stupid question in the
first six months especially because
after the six months if you ask a stupid
question now it's like what what were
you doing the last six months like were
you just faking something like that's
not good luck and if you ask these
questions and they make you feel stupid
for that that shows a lot about their
culture and that's not on you at the end
of the day always reinforce like I am
just trying to do a good job and I want
to provide a great output for you all
and so for me to do that I will need
information on this this and this and
answering these questions will be very
helpful to me and just keep on
reiterating that I hold the belief that
you can kind of say anything you want to
people as long as it's said in the right
way and so if you're a person that's
like yo I'm feeling chased by this
person she's not helping me or anything
say like okay great where can I go for
proper assistance if you're too busy
where can I go for proper assistance on
this and keep it moving that sucks that
really especially as hire that sucks
next up how do you deal with someone
that is impossible to work with this
person is unnecessarily nasty
condesending enjoys publicly pointing
out and calling out what everyone else
did wrong even if inaccurate yet takes
zero accountability for their own
actions and
mistakes I haven't met a cooworker that
likes this person for the record it is
known a known fact that they are not
very good at their job I have honestly
never encountered someone this awful to
work with
before that's sucks honestly so let's
say we're in a meeting and this person's
like oh yeah no um Nia did this is this
wrong and it was so terrible and they're
throwing me under the bus like that I
would and and the only reason I say I'm
going to say it like this is because
they themselves are apparently being
like nasty and cold in the way they're
talking to you even in front of people
from what I gather I would say okay
Nancy I appreciate your attempt to
provide feedback however the way in
which you're doing it is extremely
unproductive and does not does not
contribute to a professional work
environment so instead I ask that you
come to me if you have any
recommendations of how someone could do
this or how I could have done a better
job in a manner that is respectful and
professional I would say that you can
say anything in this world in my opinion
almost anything you just need to know
the proper to say it and by me calling
out how unproductive they are
communicating is like the way they
communicate is like everyone is going to
understand what I'm talking about and
also give me kudos for saying like no
like good job standing up for yourself
that's not okay that she's doing that
like if you're being unprofessional to
me and everyone's seeing it I'm going to
be professional in my uh pointing out of
that you know does that make sense I
know it can be like scary especially if
you're a person who doesn't like
confrontation but you know what I also
don't like being called out in front of
everybody and their mama like I'm not
playing that game I've been
overqualified for some positions I've
interviewed for can someone plead
explain the logic if I'm willing to work
in an underqualified role so I used to
be that person who didn't understand why
being
overqualified made me not get a job that
was until I got a job I was
overqualified for and I quit on the
third day didn't even show up I said I'm
sorry I'm on my way to work um this was
not like a huge job it was like a job at
an ice cream parlor I was in college um
it was like a summer job and everything
but at that point I had gotten a couple
of internships and things like that and
I was just like I had like I had
attempted to get the I had wanted the
job for like extra money but then I got
there and I was like no I see what being
overqualified means this is mind-
numbingly not a good time and so
literally on my way to work I I said
like I've never given a two weeks notice
um I called and I was like I am sorry I
can't do this it is I I cannot attend
also know that the people I was around
it was it was rough there were things in
the offices that shouldn't be in the
offices that were not necessarily legal
to be in the offices because of these
other co-workers like things like that
and so I was like no I am out I am not
associating myself with this like
goodbye however from that point on I did
understand the issue of being
overqualified if you're overqualified
for something at least this is the case
for me it is so hard to be engaged I
have never had so little brain cells
working um while I'm at work that that
was a new experience for me um and I
couldn't do it again I was just so not
engaged another issue is yes of course
all of us we work for money like let's
not pretend that I am here filling out
this paperwork because I love this pen
like that's not what we're here for I'm
here because you pay me money and you
got me here because I can provide an
output for you however there is an issue
that comes with not being able to like
teach a person something if I'm an
employer and I can't teach a person
anything or provide them ways to grow as
a professional because they were already
overal qualified when they got here that
create that does create an issue on the
working relationship and I get that it
sucks like believe especially in this
economy it sucks not getting a job
because you're
overqualified but with your question of
can someone explain it to me that's my
explanation ooh this is a fun one share
your weirdest interview moments that's
the that's the initial post and people
are going to respond to it with theirs
in at a very small Tech contracting
company in the early 2000s in DC with
the CTO and sales guy sales guy is as
young as me ask what bars I like to go
to I throw out a few he replied I like
1583 the club used Roman numerals as its
sign my eyes were bold the best trip
Club
in the best trip Club in town is that
number I terar out of reply
I've been there but I like this other
strip club better hey Chuckles sorry
you're confusing 1583 with
1782 1583 is down the street from 1782
away from Midtown not on it it's new I
choke he laughs a little then says yeah
we hit 1782 on Thursday nights after
bouncing around that broke the ice and I
felt better got the job so yes I've
talked about strip clubs in an interview
actually a nice place to work and
everyone was nice A little odd but nice
I would be
horrified especially because like you
started talking about strip clubs
because they started talking about strip
clubs and you're not you're trying to
like keep up with the
conversation that's hilarious I'm glad
that person shared that that's very very
very funny do y'all have a weird
interview experience let me know if you
do I have um not a weird interview
experience but it was a rough interview
experience I'll link it above me and if
there are any work situations or
questions that y'all have y'all are
going through Etc or any advice please
put it down in the comment section below
but no thank you so much for joining me
and I'll talk to you all soon bye oh and
don't forget to like subscribe and
comment yeah okay bye